excited to talk today about work we've
been doing a Quan site in Quonset labs
called ura
and actually to present the work of
Hamir Abbas Abbas II who isn't able to
be here today but he wrote a minute much
the materials this talk I'll start by
motivating a bit of why we've been doing
this work kind of what's what's behind
it where we're trying to accomplish and
then talk about the work itself and
where and how far we've gotten and there
is actually a thing so last year I was
kind of railing about a thing and now we
have a thing so you know sometimes the
things I'm trying to create do get
created with wonderful people like Amir
and others are on site labs that make it
possible so you are a separating in
separating interface from implementation
and we have a major problem I talked
earlier today about a major problem with
extending Python in general that we have
to solve we have another major problem
in numpy land that we have to solve
that's gonna cause technical debt and
cause major challenges for us going
forward and it's starting to emerge it's
something that's been uncovered as we
have our friends at Google and Facebook
and others build these amazing deep
learning ecosystems that sort of have
other implementations of numpy so I'm
going to talk just a little bit about
that first we'll come back to this set
of slides so the joint talk between
Hamir and I want to talk a little about
a brief history of numpy so you array is
a implementation it's basically numpy
made an interface made and it made an
implementation so if we look at numpy
and Jim Fulton he always gets on me a
little bit for showing this because he
feels like pretty impostor syndrome like
why are you putting me there but in 1994
you go back and look at the mailing list
you can see his matrix top pie that he
shared and I mention this because
sharing your code leads to good things
you don't know what it's gonna lead to
in a very direct way Jim Fulton's work
and sharing matrix I led two numpy so
you never know what's gonna happen so
share your work don't be afraid to put
it out there and let people see it and
learn and educate themselves and grow
from it so Jim hugenon
did the did the bulk of the work and
getting dumped I started as a graduate
student at mighty he wrote numeric and I
heard that a few times people have been
in the community long enough to
understand in America number a numpy
didn't come in a vacuum numpy emerged
from existing code that existed and
that's been the beautiful thing about
open source lets us build on each other
but numb but numeric didn't quite do
some things at the Hubble Space
Telescope needed as they were going to
depend on Python for their image
processing so they worked on something
called memory early days like to talk to
enjoy talking to Perry and Rick about
that but the challenge was what happened
it started to split the community and as
a sci-fi author I loved the sci-fi
community I loved how it was bringing
together a group of people sharing code
and sharing ideas to do computing with
Python and then what happened with
memory is that there are now people
reusing libraries the only work with
memory and other libraries my work was
with numeric and we've kind of building
this fractured community early on in
Python land and that really bothered me
so the basically numpy was created to
unify the REA objects in Python that
history is sometimes lost it was my
early history of why I actually started
the sci-fi project Syfy was my baby it
started way before numpy in 2000 1998
really numpy came in 2005-2006 as a
reaction to helping these this community
merge and instead of writing papers and
grants I wrote numpy and so my tenure
committee thought I didn't do enough
work and effectively I didn't get tenure
at a university because I wrote a numpy
but we had this massive community
success so I'll take that I definitely
would trade that again now the reason
it's successful today is not just
because of my work because of thousands
of other people who both used it and
contributed to it and made it part of
their own is a very social effort and it
started as a social effort I can go to
detail about those interested in knowing
how to dump I really come about but it
was a lot of personal effort to
something had there's a lot of work had
to be done it's a big community effort
fast forward 12 years now with
especially with tensorflow and PI torch
and MX net there's actually array
objects everywhere there isn't just one
numpy array that rebuilds on there's no
tensorflow doesn't build on numpy it
borrows the ideas but doesn't build on
it used the name d-type but it has its
own concept that's actually anemic but
they basically do a bunch of things new
they have there's there's paddle paddle
there's dinette there's a bunch of of
things that are out there that are not
numpy and that's okay but we based have
a divided community again
it actually makes what I did and oh you
have this nice problem of a unifying
American um array that was cute what you
did now we have this massive
Division that's happening and it's it's
a bit frustrating but it's also an
opportunity and the real problem isn't
the fact there's lots of array objects
that's okay a lot of very
implementations can be a good thing it's
the fact that people are building
software that requires one or the other
so hey you're an Edward user oh that's
fine now fortunately back in the day we
actually created something called the
buffer protocol we fixed it twice
there's an old principle of its find a
problem don't fix it don't just fix the
proc the proximate cause fix the
ultimate cause and back in the day we
didn't just write numpy we also created
the buffer protocol so that anybody
could actually share data so you
wouldn't actually at least have to copy
data back and forth between the objects
and so that helps us today because you
can actually today use a PI torch object
it's not perfectly true in all cases but
where people are using the buffer
protocol you can actually use a PI torch
object and then put a numpy wrapper
around the same memory and so that's
okay and especially you're talking about
gigabytes of data that matters but we're
still having API sort of divergence and
people aren't able to write to a common
API so they're basically I'm to choose
their array object nor to build an array
output on top of it all right so what if
anything should be done about this do we
do we you know sacrifice tenure for ten
people is that what's gonna require we
just do with this bigger problem we
sacrifice Tanner for ten people instead
of just one something has to be done or
something could be done it's an
opportunity to make the world a better
place well we had the buffer protocol so
how do we you know extend that effort
and then the other thing we did though
is actually a protocol approach we had
we built something called dunder array
interface which allowed anybody to share
even if the buffer protocol didn't exist
you could as an object export your
memory through this array interface and
we did that too back in the day some may
remember matplotlib matplotlib actually
had a project called numerix with an X
and protime numpy was going to be called
numerix except for there was a piece of
software out there called the Americas
that conflicted with but it used
so when matplotlib existed early on way
it solved the problem is instead of
importing numeric or importing numpy it
imported numerix with an X and then it
lets you choose which one of those was
you which back in you're gonna pick and
so basically we took that idea and kind
of say well let's generalize that to an
array interface and let and and kind of
do that at the same time that that's
there it exists it hasn't it's starting
to be rekindled in with the coop I coop
I now has a coup
a interface or some work in that
direction this happening but this early
protocol work actually has been
happening as well just not just not as
the buffer protocol acts there's a lot
of work and a lot of people did a lot of
work to make that possible which is
fantastic as today you can actually now
a database programmer in Python you
don't have to depend on numpy you can
actually just export them a memory view
and numpy can easily absorb that data
without copying it so it's a very
valuable tool that's in Python today but
we can go back and revisit these efforts
and in fact some of you I won't talk
today about xn d but xn d is effectively
a generalization of the buffer protocol
particularly on the type system the data
type system and it's actually a very
sophisticated story around that it's
very nice the code works it's out there
it's a set of C libraries as a reference
implementation of a concept that
basically generalizes the buffer
protocol but then the array interface we
thought what if we could kind of
generalize that and make a interface to
two functions that need to be called on
objects so you didn't have to decide
what to what implementation you were
going to use so that's what motivated
you are a your a is like what do we do
to actually help the problem of a
federally multiple dispatch the problem
of I'm Ryan I'm a library writer writing
scikit-learn I'm writing second image or
I'm running a linear algebra algorithm
and I know I need an array but don't
really care if it's a strided pointer
you know I don't care if it's actually a
numpy array it could be a pi torch array
it could be as long as it has a certain
interface that's all I care about
can we do that and then have functions
that will then just dispatch to the
different implementations as needed
it's it should be easy actually this is
Python after all we should this should
be straightforward to do but it's not
done like that part of it is not
technical part of it social part of it
because of so much dependency part of
because numpy was so darn successful now
everybody uses hood and so but it is an
implementation at the end of the day
it's not an interface it's an
implementation and it doesn't have a
well it does it this interface is not
super well defined so let's talk about
some of the challenge that exists so
many are familiar with Python 2 to
Python 3 transition how many use Python
2 how many actually do know about the
Python to Python 3 transition so that's
kind of I actually started numpy and
part of my strategy to get adoption with
numpy was to make it Python 3 like to
get that's how I got guiteau's
tenshun had was able to go to lunch with
him in San Mateo and I got him to come
meet with me and Paul Dubois to talk
about how do we make numpy happen and
part of the strategy was to say we're
gonna make this Python three thing and I
did not realize that Python 3 would sort
of take ten years fast numpy him time to
really work so but that's how we got
their attention
and got the attention of making this
part of it but Python 3 had a major
problem the major part when prathap I
thought three had was the way strings
were used in Python 2 if you're a user
of string interface in Python 2 you
basically you'd write code and you
didn't know if you if the person who
write that code meant to use a string or
they cared about the bytes because
strings and bytes were exactly the same
thing in Python 2 and even if somebody
wanted they could there's no way for
them to say there's no space for a code
author to say actually I want to use
this this collection of this string I'm
using is actually a bytes now you could
say be you people could start to say B
and they can start to use the ubehebe
strings and use strings indicate Unicode
and bytes but the code that made the
head that was the hardest to translate
and I think it's twisted it's still very
difficult to translate was code that
used that intrinsically very difficult
to move forward that was one of the key
difficulties of actually moving the
community forward was that string bytes
confusion problem so I submit we have
exactly the same problem in numpy that's
emerging and it's in the following way
and I'll bring up Hamir slides now so
this talk really give a lot of credit
Samir I'm here just representing some of
his his work missy presents there we go
and he's done a good job of sort of
talking about youõre and what he's
produced but Hamir about Abbasi he works
at Quon site labs software Deb he's
going to talk about you know you array
and numpy and you can find him on
Twitter you can file so find him it at
Kuan site he's got a H Abbasi at Kwan
site calm so numpy breaks this principle
of separate implementation from
interface so a lot of people want to use
what they want is they say Oh
scikit-learn I get this they've got this
question a lot I want to use
scikit-learn on GPUs well can I just you
know just make that happen can't you
just make a version of numpy that works
on GPUs and have scikit-learn
automatically use it
theoretically maybe but scikit-learn
goes off an import scipy and sci-fi
imports numpy and it uses numpy as an
array but what you can't tell is that
the author of sci-fi of that particular
module linear algebra did it mean to use
numpy as an array that implements
slicing and getitem or did it mean to
use an array that's implemented as a
pointer with strided memory of a
particular type you actually don't know
because there's no way to tell numpy is
what it is there it's not here's the
interface to arrays and then here's the
implementation that's numpy there's no
separation there I think that's a major
problem and right now there's some work
going on the community to say well kind
of kind of do a one over on the commute
on people like well we'll kind of shift
in this this you func protocol concept
that let's add asked user or a sci-fi
user automatically get hab das carré's
flow through that workflow automatically
and I think that'll work until it
doesn't and then when it doesn't it'll
just crash and burn horribly and you'll
be basically we're basically be stuck so
I'm nerv I'm very nervous about that
approach and everyone knows the numpy
community knows I'm nervous about the
approach but it's fine I don't know
everything it's fine to do things I
don't know about but people are
experiment that approach but
fundamentally I think this is the wrong
approach I think we obviously have to
separate interface for implementation
there's a couple there are things
working in that direction that I'm
excited about I think people are
starting to think about well let's see
if we can't make an array P I ura is a
solution so one things I'd like to do I
don't like to complain about things I
like to actually say well here's a
proposal here's something instead here's
an idea and that's that's what we're
doing with you array it's here's an idea
here's another approach here's a way to
separate implementation from interface
in a way that we believe could go
farther
so as the ecosystem grew it's kind of
this is a big numpy is a victim of its
own success lots of people used it but
it's also a victim of lack of funding so
as a lot of people were using numpy at
the same time I was not able to continue
working on numpy I had to get a job I
had to go work for that job I had to
kind of keep but I'm still in that
situation I have to provide for my
family doing things other than
project management on PI then we'll look
at you know then help numpy move forward
that's kind of a major problem we have
in the community I still think a lot of
issues we have inside by numpy pandas
beyond or because that fundamental fact
the people that work on those code
make them successful can't actually
continue to work on them they go get
hired to do something else instead of
actually make those continue to help
those projects grow and become
successful so lots of people adopted it
and segmentation starts to grow and
there's what happens is segmentation
start to go so things like task X are a
coup pi sparse X chain er PI towards
tensorflow they sort of started to mimic
that um PI API parts of it not parts of
it you know and a lot of users
downstream would use it and then sort of
expect usage of the numpy API but what
end-users really want is they want to be
able to say yeah I can I can write this
high-level library using a logical array
and just have it work with any logical
array that implements that interface so
that yeah if I is long as I have a
back-end that works with that array
interface I can use GPUs or I could use
FPGA or I could use a distributed
cluster distributed maybe the API has
changed a little bit because distributed
has some intrinsic parallelization
questions but certainly GPU is an
example of a distributed system so
shouldn't these be code compatible
shouldn't you be able to choose the
implementations separately from the API
right I submit we need to be able to
enable that you need to make it
intentional so and I'd love this to be
an umpire if numpy itself just said
somebody could say from numpy dot api
import so that people know that you're
actually using the api not that you
don't care about the implantation as
opposed to currently you don't know if
somebody importance numpy you don't know
if they just care about what do they
care about which methods do they really
care about so that's what we have to fix
I think fundamentally it's a it's down
stream libraries that have to be able to
tell us what they mean so some would
offer them PI interface without streams
implementation others did their own
thing a lot of people doing some of
their own thing but if numpy was cleanly
separated to interface to implementation
what would have happened I think
different things would have happened I
think there was a chance that I and I
you know I'm sitting there remembering
growing the API but remember the time
the API also also emerged as a
unification of two other libraries so
numb PI's API is big because it was
solving a problem of bringing two
communities together so it had to kind
of be big enough to support both those
communities but that doesn't mean that's
the API that everybody should be
building on downstair
and what we needed to do as well as
create kind of here's the array
interface that downstream library
authors can depend on and that's the
work we didn't do which I think we can
you know what can we do now
can we get unstuck what's the answer and
this is a common problem an open source
actually is you kind of things get there
because of lots of reasons and then
people use it and I okay what do we do
now in a larger organization and we just
create we refactor we put investment
resources into and we build on top of it
where is that going to come from and
this is one reason I care so much about
funding of open source and connecting
companies and the money being made to
the open source community because I see
problems that have to be fixed and I
don't know how to fix them without
resources without budget so can we get
up stuck as we build an abstraction
right there's no problem that can't be
solved by another layer of indirection I
don't know who said that but it's true
it's actually true it's but it can be
slower that way I like this quote to
Humira put this and the purpose
abstraction ought to be vague would be
create a new semantic level in which fun
can be absolutely precise that's we're
trying to do put a semantic level in
where you can be very precise about what
you mean so what's happening now in the
numpy community is there something
called array you func which started as
numpy you func and said hey I want to
build a you thunk can I just do this
dunder protocol thing and and that kind
of works okay part of the reason that
works okay is because you thunks through
a smaller thing that not many people use
them that's pretty straightforward and
limited as to what the API looks like so
now you you could overload and you can
overload now you as an as an array
implementer can implement this dunder
array you func and then all you function
numpy will defer to you and call your
dunder a you func it's actually a
reasonable approach I wasn't I was it
wasn't my favorite approach like my my
preferred approach has been for a few
years that we just implement proper
multi methods we just implement a proper
abstraction mechanism to actually
register functions with multiple
implementations based on the types
that's called with if you think about
multi methods what they are at their
core multi methods are object-oriented
programming lets you create an object
and then have methods that are called
and if you think about what ends up
happening if you can if you instantiate
another object and call its method your
having single argument
dispatcher dispatching on the first
argument which is self to the method to
call and you're calling a different
method based on the object that's
instantiating so a single argument
dispatch that works great until you have
well now I want to actually I'm gonna
add two numbers I have a left off-brand
the right operand I'm gonna add those
two concepts well which one do I choose
if which which if I two of two different
objects there which of those two objects
add methods should I call and Python has
a solution to that with dunder methods
as are ad and are mul okay great that's
- what if you have three arguments what
about forearms what about five arguments
well the solution that is multi methods
Julie implements that dial and
implements that if an implement iams
there's some real challenging technical
problems in terms of what do I do if I
then sub type a second into that I think
for most people it's a pretty
straightforward thing to do to just
think about registering and
implementation for the types you and you
insert in fact that's what numpy does
with you folks you func some of the
covers are a multiple met are a multi
method implementation that's what how
they work how does numpy know when you
call add on an array of two integer
arguments how does it know to
differentiate that
what's machine code is a call
differentiating that from calling add on
a float arguments well it's a multi
method you've registered a different
implementation register a different
kernel let's bring that up and so that
Python has proper multi methods now Matt
Rahman did that there's a package called
multiple dispatch there is a mechanism
for this it's one mechanism any but how
do we make this more ubiquitous that's
the approach I would take I was actually
just have multi multi dispatch mobile
methods be more ubiquitous in Python
there's some challenges with that
there's some challenges of the biggest
challenge is actually one of global
versus local scope if you think about a
multiple dispatch mechanism somewhere
there's register there's a table that's
registered about where things get called
that's basically a global table
somewhere like with object oriented that
table is attached to the object itself
and so it's contained in that scope
kind of a little better so where do you
put that table when you're talking about
this kind of a thing that's good that's
there's are some real questions it can
be attached to module objects I mean one
approach is attached to module object in
Python so it's contained that module
object anywhere that modulus is
instantiated it's a new thing I think
there are solutions to that
but that becomes one of the one of the
questions that's real deep question
compared to let me funnel things through
a through a funk through a functional
approach and particularly to start
talking about parallelism I started
talking I'm gonna run this code here I'm
gonna run this code over here how do I
make sure that when I'm running this
code and it's got a particular mobile
dispatch mechanism I have the same code
over here
like I haven't somehow changed my module
over here how do I keep things contained
those are fundamental questions actually
in in computer science that mean that
people have different opinions about
this right so one of the advantages of
the protocol methods is protocols are
attached to the object itself so it's
kind of all there and some some can
argue the deaths that's a better
approach so array you func is firing I
was kind of efficacy a plus 0.5 on a
regular
ok that's fine but would rather see
multiple dispatch handled it's not
enough now we cannot now we have a Rea
function or a function tries to take
more of the methods in Python more of
the methods in done by things like a
recreation things like linear algebra
now you can do a rate function actually
it's been not enough there's actually
four or five more protocols that have to
be there and so there what's happening
in the numpy communities are trying to
take the numpy epa as it is and kind of
then protocol i's it i have several
concerns about that one of them is
there's too many the api is bigger or
too big anyway we should restrict that
numbs that api actually be intentional
about what api we're going to make an
interface around not just kind of what's
there because of history let's actually
be intentional and create an array api
that makes sense and we have a lot of
code out there to help us guide that
question at the moment and then more and
more so you array is a different
solution you are a how is an
implementation of this mobile dispatch
mechanism and the ability to coercion
it creates an abstraction and you'll see
examples how it works in a second along
with other goodies you can basically
with you array create a version of numpy
to let you switch the backend easily you
can switch the backend to GPUs to Dass
to coop i easily and then have it all
flow through it follows this separation
of concerns and it makes it possible for
numpy to be an interface at least on the
python level there's another question
about the sea level of numpy interface
so we have to see my ii python talk for
how we're going to solve that so here's
an example of how it actually works this
is working code
yurei exists today it's not just an idea
you Python just an idea you array is not
an idea it's a real code it works you
can go download it install it start
using it
so there's ura and then there's you
numpy you raise kannan miss named really
because it's not it's really you array
is really you dispatch you array is a
way to build multiple dispatch
mechanisms it for anything not just a
raise but for anything you want so okay
but kind of historically it got named
ura so you you are a lets you set up
back end to a context so within this
context all the numpy all the code in
you numpy now dispatches based on the -
back-end alright so this so import you
numpy as NP a lot of people do import
numpy as NP if you just import you numpy
so a couple things first of all you're
intentionally saying I'm actually
looking for the interface to numpy not
numpy itself so you're not saying
important numpy and pretend that it
works with tasks I'm saying import you
numpy and tell people that actually you
are trying to use an array interface and
not just an not just an implantation and
now set it back end the default back end
for you numpy is numpy so you don't if
you don't set it back and it'll assume
you meant numpy and off it goes but you
can set it back end and now NP ones
returns a task array and you can do
anything with x and it's - the hole all
the way so that's how it works
you can also nest backends you can about
a coupie array instead of a task erase
you can with - back end with coop i you
can actually have a coop hi array of
coop i of GPU arrays on Basques arrays
and that works too then the changes
probably all along down the stack now
that's true as long as there's some
there's some there's some see stuff
under the covers again but part of this
is good the goal i think the work we
still have to do is for the numpy
community to sort of create an api level
that isn't magic that is basically this
is an API that's commedia can be
reimplemented so currently this you
could you choose app you can also choose
it back in for a sub module like if you
have numpy fft or numpy earn some you
can actually choose a particular runtime
for that module and you can you can
change that it can all be done at
runtime and this isn't done by monkey
patch you don't know if you know what
that term is monkey patching is the idea
pythons so generic you can actually just
go get the object and assign the
attributes to something else at runtime
and you can do that and in fact some the
one example that there's a few examples
that are pre interesting but gee event
does that to change all the i/o loops
you know to basically use code before
co-routines early age of use green lists
out of the covers but by doing this you
can get rid of of kind of evil monkey
patching that a few other vendors
provide basically that has made some of
the community a little unhappy so
there's two protocols instead of like in
the twenty so you a function you a
convert you a function is how you
actually build your it's it's borrowing
the ideas of a rate function but instead
of forcing it through numpy arrays it's
allowing you because you've defined a
new interface you can do a lot more and
you're not constrained and then also
you're communicating correctly to users
who anybody using you numpy is telling
everybody they care about an interface
not a particular implementation all
right so what if you could do something
like this get use the new users just
like numpy with no back end without
switching so there's there's basically
been some work the UA has is current
work it's currently working code it
works it's actually used for Sai PI's
fft module in fact there's a Python
implementation than a C++ implementation
of you're ready to make it faster and
that version is used by Sai PI to allow
the sci-fi fft module to switch between
implementations of how it actually
implements the site pfft modules so it's
working code working today now that
we've been talking to the numpy
community about how you know okay how
does this help the numpy problem could
it be used couldn't find a pen on it and
appropriately that's a big deep question
and a lot of there's a lot of debate
going on about that and it's good debate
it's really getting it's led to some
real interesting conversations one thing
I really like about this led to recently
it's numpy starting to really think
about ok maybe we just need an umpire
API module or a module that has allows
people to indicate that they have a
interface or trying to trying to do so
there's an app actually that's that's
being discussed
so that's you're a happy to take
questions talk about we have about
fifteen minutes here it's um gosh it
would be a great time for a demo here
but I don't have one that's what happens
when it's Amir's code and mirrors
hem mirrors laptop and he's not here to
give it but he would give a beautiful
demo that shows how to use it but that's
the idea the idea is it really intended
to be very simple for Cyprus for the
idea would be Sai PI and Sai kit and
other users downstream users would use
you RA would use you numpy in particular
instead of numpy if they want to
indicate their caring about in reg
interface and not particular implant
ation so look for more work in this
direction if it's you are a high level
API is like going forward I would say
you numb ura is here it's a multiple
dispatch mechanism that works it's being
used by Sai PI so it'll continue how far
it spreads will kind of depend on the
next several months you know 12 to 18
months a lot of work is being done into
okay how do we we're working with Intel
and and a few other vendors to talk
about high level API s for arrays data
frames and data types that may use you
array it's not guaranteed we're gonna
use your array but we might I mean it's
basically we're trying to make that
separation a real thing and so that's
that's the other initiative you'll see
on open teams is that effort to really
unify array computing and data frame
computing around API is the supposed to
have implementations so that's the next
really two years of work of innovation
worker quan site will be around some of
that so a new array fits into that
category as a particular implementation
yeah
you actually started answering the
question but I want to to continue and
go deeper and to specific examples of
applications of what you think might be
possible if you're if you're allowed to
talk about this and I know that
something may be oh I think I'm allowed
to talk about any of this yeah I just
can't I probably just can't mention
names yet but I can definitely tell that
ideas examples so we can visualize it
better how how impactful it will be
because it's good questions so for you
as an end-user of pandas you probably
won't see it right you'll keep using
pandas what you'll notice is suddenly
GPUs work you know suddenly I can
migrate to new runtime something it's
not oh hey I've got this cootie F but
right now what's happening is we have
new implementations coming out hey I'm
working data frames on GPUs and it's a
whole new namespace right oh so if one
data frames on GPUs that's suddenly a
different namespace
why is that you know we're kind of going
backwards a bit where you know back to
the days of oh I've got new hardware I
got to write a different computing
language I can't just you know I have
all these different libraries import
doesn't happen back in the C days I
would I would have I wrote C code and it
was supposed to be cross-platform but it
couldn't actually target new hardware
unless I use these particular includes
this particular set of libraries we're
kind of getting there in the Python
world where oh I want to use GPUs I've
got to use kudiye for I've got to use
puh ml I can't use scikit-learn
that's not ideal because there's an end
user that's an implementation detail
where it runs and how the compute works
is an in-place detail so it's this isn't
a spirit of that you as an end user very
likely what I don't imagine you'd ever
use you array or you numpy right unless
because you might actually you might if
you're basically wanting to write sorry
that's not true you might write a script
uses you dump I if what you want to do
is write a script that says I want to
use an array interface and then I want
to try it with tasks and I want to try
it with GPUs and I want to try it with
and you know I want to try with anything
you might today that's what you do is
you use you numpy and if we had a you
pandas we don't yet but you pandas would
basically be like import you pandas as
PD and so you could still use
he'll use the same API you're used to
but now you know that the implementation
can be different and you're not having
to deal with you're not having to deal
with those consequences it allows it
allows library out there it allows the
backend generator you're just waiting
for someone to write that back in as
soon as they do it's off to the races
for you so if numpy had been built with
you numpy that question i got all the
time of can I get scikit-learn working
on GPUs I could have said yes that'll be
a weekend and we'll get that working
it's getting today with the rate with a
rate function and the fact that Koopa
has a rate function and that psyche is
getting there to use sci fi functions
with the rate function you can me it
might what I fear is the demo will work
and people are successfully using the
array function today and it's working to
some degree I would just real I would
personally hesitate to tell some and put
that in production and rely on it that's
that's where I'm at and so this is
something I could comfortably build and
say something this will work and we can
we make sure this works so we're not
gonna have funny corner cases everywhere
but that's a debatable question right
now and that's currently the the
conversation that's happening so I do
think ultimately we're gonna have to
think hard about the name space I'd love
to see numpy as the name space continued
but it's already not continuing because
we have tensorflow torch and and others
as namespaces that people are doing
arrays so for me the the pandas
namespace I think is safer because it's
gonna be easier for us to use this take
technology under the covers in pandas
because pan is already as a high level
interface but but so for examples as an
end user it's hard to say it's still
very early today you can use them you
numpy if you'd like it works and it's a
very straightforward piece of code it's
not a complicated piece of code to
support we're gonna keep supporting it
for the nut for the SyFy use cases all
it needs is backends and those backends
will be generally applicable to other
code bases as well so it's not like
you're you're you're you're stuck I
don't know if that helps but it's a
little bit you know actually writing a
back-end is a little bit confused I mean
it's not like it's it's it's super-easy
I would say the interface right our
back-end is still it's still meant for
computer scientists
I have some really brilliant engineers
at Quonset labs I love them but
sometimes they build interfaces that
look like they're built for other
computer scientists yeah it's it's you
know I kind of litmus test because I'm a
scientist from the heart if I look at
someone go yeah I have to put on my
computer science have to understand what
you did there maybe we can do better we
can build a better interface that makes
it a little easier to communicate we're
talking about we're still working on
that I would say but there's some
there's some really works today what's
their works it's capable and there's
actually a really fast C++
implementation as well so if you look at
no API authors it's not too bad but
effectively you have you have to
generalize the concept of I have this
function I want to make I want if I have
a function I want to make multiple
method make a multi method I have to
kind of abstract the concept of the
function and have an argument extractor
are going to replace her and I have to
kind of think at a high level like that
so you know you have to you can
implement as you 8ua a function you a
convert or the two ones and you can see
you a function takes a signature method
args keyword args basically tell it
takes the generic the the concepts and
then there's some examples here but so
that's you array you array is one of
several projects at one site that are in
this direction later I think tomorrow
Saul will be talking about a concept
called meta DSL which actually takes
this and goes one step up to the ast
level so this this is let's call it
immediate mode you're basically working
you haven't you have an object it
dispatches to an implementation and it's
happening immediately using the syntax
of fightings in the Python runtime meta
DSL is about using the syntax of Python
and then inserting and capturing as the
syntax is created to rewrite what it
calls it actually is a higher level and
it's more powerful because of that a
little harder to understand but it lets
you it's it relate it to the graph mode
tensorflow and Pytor to both introduced
immediate mode and graph mode you array
is a mobile dispatcher mechanism on the
immediate mode meta DSL is a way to
dispatch different runtimes at the
compile time at the ast AB second
abstract syntax tree level so you can
basically oh this syntax rewrites to
anything it's quite a bit more powerful
and lets you do interesting interesting
kinds of things like target the IR ml IR
lets you target all kinds of runtimes
that you are target new runtimes not
just new functions so we've been doing
several several bit a lot of research in
this direction to see how to solve this
problem at a fundamental level while
also integrating with all the tools that
are out there because the community is
spread there's a lot of cool tools out
there that we want to make sure and take
advantage of the whole goal is to reuse
what's there not to rewrite the world
but to reuse and how do we do that and
still make the experience seamless for
the end user or as seamless as possible
for the end user so that's the general
goal all right well thank you appreciate
it give you some time back but let me
know if you have any questions and and I
can pass them along to the team and and
we'll let you know thanks
you